oh this is some [ __ ]
how dare you
[Music]
i'm craig robinson from killing it on
peacock and also the bad guys
are coming out april 22nd killing it
april 14th
should we start off
and i'm here to answer the internet
if you can see a sex tape with any two
movie characters who would it be
easy
betty boop
mufasa
[Laughter]
would you rather have all music or all
tv be in spanish
oh tv because those those weather girls
you know
would you rather have free strippers for
life or free pizza for life pizza boom
no question if you can make any two
people fight in a no rules cage match
who would you choose
uh the mountain
from uh
yeah and then uh mike tyson
would you rather be the world's tallest
man
or world's
shortest man tallest
you're not gonna fit in any planes any
cars yeah but you can like kick the [ __ ]
out of people
two buttons you can only press one
hey instantly get a million dollars b
have a 50 50 chance you get
100
million dollars
b i'm good because you're rich so i'm
good again
what how about you get uh 10 million
guaranteed to me oh yeah i'll take that
oh yeah for sure where where where's the
cut off
oh well
would you do it for five million when
she's not pushing the button
um
i'm gonna do five million i'll go yeah
if you wanna
would you rather fight a short gladiator
or a rhino
short gladiator sure yeah i'm the
tallest guy in the world
would you rather always have the hiccups
or always have a headache hiccups i had
a headache yesterday it was horrible
you're on set you're trying to act
hiccup the
the hiccup master boom
if you could get access to one person's
phone and look at all their [ __ ] who
would it be
whoa
let me see my ex-girlfriend
let's see i'm gonna prove she cheated
what would you pick to be the title of
your autobiography
let's do this
okay
would you rather have to always wear
jeans or shorts
james
would you rather be drunk 24 7 or never
be drunk again i'll never be drunk again
i would take never be drunk again down
in new orleans you're hanging out with
danny mcbride not allowed to touch it
never be drunk again you know why
because then i'll never have any more
hangovers yeah that's it
bacon or sausage oh this is some
[ __ ]
how dare you
i think it's easy
bacon oh no no sir no bacon i have to go
no bacon
i have to go with bacon because you know
what it sizzles imagine not having bacon
bacon and eggs sausage and eggs sausage
egg and cheese on a bagel i mean come on
this is crazy duck
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications make sure you click thumbs
up for the like hit that bell icon